let's go back here in southern Nevada
have you ever just looked around your
house ever thought about adding some
color well this morning we have an
example of that one example perhaps the
valley man hired local artists to
completely deck out this house and now
you can buy it here's Lauren negretti
joining us live at the Spring Valley
graffiti house as it's called the wall
behind you tells the tale Lauren good
morning
hey good morning yes there is so much to
see here from samario to some Marvel to
just plain Viva Las Vegas right here
this house is truly a live-in art piece
now it's a three bedroom home two bath
recently lowered to 8.95
000 and Ivan Phillips and his family
bought the home as a blank slate 11
years ago they hired some local artists
to fix that
and we would think well why can't we
have this in our house because this
house is very unique with the
architecture because it has the big
wolves and obviously not many people
have that kind of um space in a house
where they can put artwork up
they're selling to move into a bigger
house one with a pool meantime he says
there are still blank spaces upstairs in
that lofted area he hopes whoever
decides to purchase the house adds to
the art now Philip's favorite piece out
here back out here live is actually the
floor with this whole glitter in layout
here very very Vegas metallic glitter
inlay you guys my favorite piece has to
be the kitchen here both with these
Campbell's Tomato Soup cans and little
Mario coming out of the pipe also peep
Luigi there in the back so a whole lot
to see don't go anywhere because coming
up at 6 a.m we'll have a live interview
with his realtor for now live in Spring
Valley Lauren negrady 8 news now so
Lauren um two bedroom two bath and
what's the price tag
895 000. 8.95
8.95 okay
I wonder if he's willing to budge on
that price yeah well I would assume uh
that it would come with some spare paint
if you have to touch it up a little bit
maybe there's some a whole bunch of
Dutch boy in the garage right a little a
little extra fun Lauren thank you for
that artists yeah it's very very unique
I feel like we've seen another house
like that recently the doodle house oh
you're right
no that's I mean it's incredible and
Sherry you kind of mentioned it it does
it would hide the flaws you know it
would your kid opens the door or you do
and too fast you know and you leave that
door knob on the drywall that's how it
all started how do I cover this hole in
the wall I'll paint something oh it's an
eye right what a great idea